it's been a little while since I've done
a personal video for my viewers and
subscribers and faith through into my
laughs an excellent opportunity for
engaging and a bit of reflection because
I have not had my laptop which turns out
to be an incredibly important tool for
me for about two weeks so this video is
some of my reflections on that and you
know a little bit of discussion of how
that happened and what I have to look
forward to and what it's like to work on
this this Big Mac and other related
topics so about two weeks ago just after
I finished up going to shower shut up
and right session here in Milwaukee
where I can my laptop and I was working
I think on a blog piece having to do
with Socrates and Epictetus you know
some interesting stoic stuff I noticed
that the battery wasn't charging on the
laptop if I go well that's a little bit
weird and as a service battery so I
thought okay I better look that up and
then things just started unraveling from
that point on it was not booting up
properly the you know when you boot up
on an apple you see that little line go
maybe it does something similar on
Windows it's been too long and I don't
quite remember it stuck and then I went
to my iPhone fortunately every course
and I look up okay what do you do then I
tried this technique and this technique
that involves holding different buttons
down and and restarting it and we we
tried just about everything fortunately
I did get it to reboot on some occasions
but it wouldn't stay on it would freeze
up and then I'd have to reboot it again
and that sometimes it would take several
times before it would reboot and then
and sometimes I could never get it to
reboot and once I left it alone for you
know hours at a time so it was clear
that there was some sort of problem once
I got it to to actually stay rebooted
for a while I backed up everything good
thing I did since I hadn't packed
anything up for a lifetime lesson to
learn
talk about that in the reflections part
and you know we started doing some
deeper digging ran a whole bunch of ng
environments updated this updated that
made sure that we did we did did help
all the disk things that you're supposed
to do all the recommended stuff and it
was still having trouble so now it's
time to actually talk to the Apple Store
we made an appointment I brought it in
by this time where we're talking about
four or five days and the computer just
not being useful am I getting the work
done that I needed to could get done
either on the iPhone or on our big Mac
here which I was fortunate that we had
was the whole story about that and I'll
tell in a bed and when I took it into
the Apple store something really weird
happened so we go to the you know the
pack and he's working on it and they
have all sorts of really cool you know
mid-level diagnostic stuff that you just
don't have access to as a user and he's
you know playing around that sure enough
the battery is shot they can tell that
right away and there was something else
a video linkage thing that was flagged
as potentially problematic so they try
to run Diagnostics on it and lo and
behold the machine at every opportunity
sort of resisted having Diagnostics run
on it and it would freeze up the
Diagnostics themselves would would
freeze up halfway through and we tried
about five different things to check
this out check that out and now we're
starting to talk about cost and
replacements and and all those sorts of
things that I'm thinking about great you
know that that's going to be a big
problem and I'm starting to get a bit
you know llama but I was already getting
a bit depressed not being able to use
the laptop effectively
thinking what might be going wrong with
it so now the verdict is we're going to
have to leave it there and have them do
deep level Diagnostics you know they got
to take it in the back and do whatever
magic the Apple people do and they'll
figure out you know whether it's a
hardware problem or software problems a
software problem
no big deal is but it's you know
uninstall the leads you know get rid of
everything and redo it if it's a
hardware problem now we might have some
some real issues and so I leave it there
and you know day passes and other day
passes and now we're like well what is
the deal here what's going on
and start getting you know a call from
we start trying to call the Apple people
but we can you know we end up getting
Apple care because the phones are not
working right at the Apple store that
we're going to so that's a lot of you
know back and forth a lot of hours
consumed with this or a thing but long
story short this machine is just giving
them all sorts of trouble you know
reading between the lines they're still
not able to figure out whether it's a
software problem a hardware problem just
we know the battery shot but the battery
can't be replaced just by itself that
requires your placement of other stuff
as well
and one story short I go you know
basically a whole week without a laptop
go to our our family reunion can't do
any work during during that time
remotely except on my iPhones and get
back and find out I have to go into the
Apple store to actually find out that
what they're going to do is replace the
whole thing
I think essentially they must have at
some point given up on it and said you
know we can't actually get to the bottom
of what's wrong with this one we're
spending a lot of hours on doing
Diagnostics and so the good news is that
I'm going to get a refurbished laptop
pretty you know pretty cost-effectively
the bad news is it takes one to two
weeks for that to come in this is the
end now of week one the business week
from Monday to Friday that I haven't
handed a laptop and I'm just waiting
around to find out what the deal is so
it could be a whole nother week and
perhaps even to the Monday after that
before I see the new laptop and that can
get my old data that I've got out of
hard drives put it on there and get back
to work but that's actually you know
good news bad news so it's up to me to
learn how to adapt and work without the
laptop you're using this this Big Mac
and you know this little tiny keyboard
here that doesn't work please function
for my big old fingers but it is you
know very effective and I got some good
experience in using it in the past for
one that I do on my video editing on
anyway so so that's the faction have
been but it is going to be a bit of a
time and it's going to be replaced you
know pretty pretty cost-effectively so
that that's actually good news and then
it's essentially a new machine with a
little bit more juice under the hood
than the previous version so actually
you know what do you think about it all
cold although there's some some real
inconveniences it's turning out that's a
bet although the being the realest that
I am I do you want to wait until the
very end when I have the machine in my
hand and everything works properly and
all my data is is there back in place
and I'm back to work at full efficiency
before I say that everything is great
but that's that's the story so far now
here are my reflections the things that
I've learned through going through this
experience the first one is I am super
dependent when it comes to writing and
doing quite a few other things that are
important for the line work that I'm in
I haven't
a laptop and you know it's not working
right that affects my mood that makes me
anxious about things that makes me a
little bit more susceptible to getting
down about things or irritated about
things and that's that's not good so
that's the all stuff I need to work on
independence of having a laptop or not
having a laptop that's a sign that I
need to be doing the kind of exercises
and you know other things that I do in
terms of you know thinking about
emotions and all that for myself the
other thing is really there are quite a
few things that can be done on a desktop
computer that are more difficult for me
to do there this doesn't mean they're
more difficult per se but you know
writing saying the kind of blog writing
that I do or writing for books or even
writing emails is just not as easy for
me on a keyboard this size and I'm not
quite sure why the laptop is really the
same keyboard but there's something
about the way it sits in my lap or is
configured that I end up you know with
the laptop I don't end up in a hitting
the wrong keys but somehow I do on this
so that's good for me to know I also
realize how convenient it was not to be
tethered to a desk and this is from
somebody for who for years and years and
years didn't have a laptop as a matter
of fact I have a desktop I would say
well I think my first computer I got
visited like you know 1990 19 1991
because my firt my freshman year of
college I actually used a typewriter the
entire time and then my my friend Edie
who has his own computer company
thankfully suggested to me I needed to
get with the times and get a computer to
help help get you set up with that
so from 1991 all the way to 2008 when I
was issued a laptop
my job at Fayetteville State University
all that time I was using the desktop
and I actually can look down on people
laptops is being a little pointy twenty
pretentious and then I got a laptop and
I thought Holden's kind of nice I can go
anywhere and work and for a long time I
had a laptop that was a you know PC
laptop and that was that was good and
then we replaced it with the Mac that
that I currently have that's out being
refreshed so in way it's not as a man
but it don't make it a thing Mac and I
just become used to being able to go
anywhere and work I can go you know down
to other places at our apartment I can
sit up my chair I don't have to sit here
at this desk in order to work I can go
to the library if I watch or watch a
museum to go to a cafe and the other
thing is you know you've got so much
power in that machine that machine is
just as powerful as this desktop except
when it comes to see a few cool things
that this can do and you know you get
used to having that capacity to just
like get online immediately me with a
client in Australia by Skype and then
you know start working on a piece for a
blog and immediately shift to answering
some emails and going on and on and on
so I have become very aware of just how
precarious this is and then you can't
really for me do things quite as
effectively on your iPhone or on the the
desktop so that's actually good luck I'm
going to be much more conscious about
how lucky I am to have a laptop I think
and I'll probably I imagine be a bit
more conscious of making sure that
nothing nothing else that are once again
threatens my use of the laptop so I'll
be a bit more careful with it as a piece
of machinery you know
I quite rough up on things banging them
around sometimes you know spilling food
and all that so a great object lesson
for me like I said it's been about two
weeks so that's a long time to observe
all this sort of stuff I also realized
that how important it is that I begin
backing up data not daily necessarily
but at least weekly because I don't want
to ever feel that anxiety or what about
all these files you know God forbid they
they shouldn't work I want to have some
stuff that doesn't you know at least two
places and have that awesome I pull em
in scheduling time for myself to do that
at least once a week and making sure
that that I follow through on that so
then it is the whole story a lot of
frustrations at the beginning some
anxiety about what it was going to mean
in terms of cost in terms of not being
able to get things done two weeks into
it it's not quite so bad and I actually
feel quite grateful about all of the
years that I had good years out of that
machine I'm looking forward to seeing
the new machine with my old data
populated back onto it I do I have
gotten a renewed appreciation for what I
can do with the Big Mac up here and you
know I've still been able to do work
just meet with my clients and put a
meeting with them somewhere else bye-bye
a Skype I meet with them here in this
room you know my video work I'm still
able to get that done here and so it
actually turned out to be except for the
writing part you know writing blog stuff
writing stuff for classes it's actually
turned out to be not not so bad so there
is the whole story